في اولي تحرك ممهد لحكومه الرئيس التونسي
قيس سعيد هذا العام بدا موظفوا شركه النقل
الحكوميه اضرابا للاحتجاج على التاخر في
دفع المكافات والاجور ما ادى الى شل حركه
نقل البري المتحدث باسم شركه نقل تونس
اكدت ان الوضع المالي في شركه صعب اضراب
اليوم فجر غضبا عاما بين الاف الاشخاص
الذين لم يجدوا وسائل للتنقل في العاصمه
فيما اعتبر استعراض قوه من الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل الذي يتمتع بالنفوذ وقد
تعهد سابقا لتنظيم سلسله احتجاجات
متابعه تطورات هذا الملف مع مراسل فونكات
من تونس العاصمه نور الدين امباركي اهلا
بك نوردين بدايه
ضعنا في صوره وحجم هذا الاضراب الذي بدات
او بدا الموظفون بالقيام به تنديدا
واحتجاجا لعدم حصولهم على المكافات
والاجور هل من تفاصيل اخرى
المنظومه تحت الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
كافه وسائل النقل البري في اقليم تونس
الكبرى وخاصه الحافلات وايضا المترو طبعا
هذا في اقليم تونس الكبرى العديد من
التونسيين او المدينه التونسيين في
العاصمه يستعملون هذه الخطوط في التنقل
والتحول الى مقارات اعمالهم وايضا الى
المدارس والجمعيات وبالتالي صباح اليوم
كان هناك شهاده تام وسط العاصمه في وسائل
النقل البري وتزامنا هذه الاضراب مع وقع
فيه شارك فيها المئات من اعوان شركه النقل
امام مقر رئاسه الحكومه وذلك طالب ماديه
تتعلق اساسا بالتمديد والاحتجاج على تاخير
صرف رواتبهم لشهر ديسمبر
ويحصل للمره الثانيه خلال شهرين
بالاضافه الى المطال يمين يا حم- اخرى الى
حدود هذه اللحظه الاضراب ما زال متواصلا
الجامعه العامه للنقل تقول ان هذا الاضراب
سيبقى مفتوحا الى حين تحقيق مطاليبهم من
خلال التشاور مع الطرف الحكومي اي مع
رئاسه الحكومه وايضا وزاره الماليه طبعا
هذا الاضرار ياتي ايضا قبل الاضراب العام
الذي دعت اليه الجامعه العامه الاعلامي
يوم 25 جانفي المقبل لمده يومين وذلك
سيشمل النقل البري والبحري وايضا الجوي
احتجاج على الوضع الذي وصلت اليه مؤسسات
النقل عمومي هناك تزمر وهناك ايضا حاله
احتقان لدى المواطنين على خلفيه هذا
الاضرار الذي بدا انطلاقا بعد عطله مدرسيه
من ذلك في حي الانطلاقه هناك احتجاج وهناك
ايضا احتقان بين
المواطنين هذا الى جانب ان هذا الاضرار
تزامنا مع اضراب جزئي لسيارات النقل
التكسي او سيارات الاجره بالتالي فان
الوضع الى حدود هذه اللحظه يتسموا
بالاحتقال ايضا بعض الجامعات اعلنت عن
تعليق او تاجيلي امتحانات وذلك على خلفيه
هذا الاضراب هناك مشاورات تجري الان بين
الطرفا من الحكومي وطرف النقابي في محاوله
لايجاد حل لهذه الازمه فقط
امام كل هذه الاحداث المتسارعه امام كل ما
تم الاعلان عنه من تصعيد ما الذي اقتراحات
هو تقترحه الحكومه
يعني الحكومه الى حدود هذه اللحظه على
الاقل في ملف وزاره النقل او في ملف النقل
العمومي ما زالت لم تتحدث لكن قبل قليل
فقط المتحدثه الرسميه باسم شركه نقل تونس
قالت بانه تم صرف اجور وايضا المنح لاعوال
النقل منذ مساء الجمعه الفرض وتقول ايضا
انه هناك صعوبات في الماليه العموميه
وبالتالي هي تعتبر انه الممثله موضوعيه
خارجه عن الشركه لكن بالنسبه لاعواد شركه
ومتمسكون الحدود هذه اللحظه بمصالين خاصه
ان هذا الامر متكرر طبعا ازمه الماليه
العموميه وازمه المؤسسات العموميه هي جزء
من النقاش بين الحكومه الاتحاد العام
التونسي الشغل والاتحاد العام التونسي
الشغل الذي يتهم الحكومه بالسعي الى
التفويت في المؤسسات العموميه استجابه الى
توصيات صندوق النقد الدولي في ما الحكومه
وايضا الرقص الرئيس سعيد يؤكد انه لا مجال
التفويت في المؤسسات العموميه الوضع ده
احنا نقول انه من ناحيه اجتماعيه بخير هذا
الاضراب يؤكد ان الوضع الاجتماعي في حاله
احتقان خاصه انه خلال هذا الشهر هناك ايضا
دعوات الاحتجاجات اولا من قبل الاتحاد
العام التونسي الشغل الذي يقوله ان هيئته
الاداريه الوطنيه ستجتمع لتحديد اشكال
احتجاجيه لاحقه وايضا اعوان الشركه
التونسيه الكهرباء والغاز وهي من اهم
وابرز الشركات ايضا لديهم اضراب نهايه
الشهر الجاري نعم شكرا جزيلا لك على كل
هذه التفاصيل من تونس العاصمه وراسل